an Ohio teacher who was told to resign  because she said that using students  preferred pronouns violates her religion  has now sued the school and this is  going to be as as it has been with the  issue of LGBT rights and gay marriage  around okay you've legalized gay  marriage well we're going to shift our  Focus the right said to claims of  religious discrimination against us this  is exactly what we are seeing here she  said it is against her religion and what  her religion teaches her to use the  pronouns that the students wanted her to  use now of course this is another one of  these complete and total messes out of  which usually no one comes out ahead but  we are going to see ultimately what the  legal decision is expect much more of  this forthcoming this is the new attack  and we know that this stuff is really  titillating to the right